she took Instagram so they played a clip
from one of your parents cups on
cigarettes but guess what they say
Bert is fat [__] off email me burns fat
why is anyone they like to [__] oh [__]
oh [__] it's that [__] time
[__]
[Music]
you might put the liquid athlete comes
before smoking what you in the water
[Music]
you see this [__] sneeze will be
bloody
couldn't bring Cheongju [__]
[Music]
that's how we show up [__] two
days late we don't give a [__] [__]
happens things happen the heat my
[__] Buchan is [__] but here we
are [__] episode 400 somebody
stole the bong what do we do we wouldn't
got another one
this is cousins with the meal there's
the little meal right here this is as we
call them a little movie a little Milito
for your culito are you guys doing
tonight
I missed you too I missed you long story
short will tell you doing the [__]
podcast what happened power I got the
virus not to his just a regular [__]
thing
the hip can't hit me I swam in the
Hudson River you swam in the Hudson
River you can eat 10 [__] crack close
with a head you found salad in with a
cavity and bad breath dude I'm saying
[Music]
we're gonna do get the party started
early tonight
I missed you what are you gonna do I've
been busy
like Luton 48 hours oh [__]
[Music]
at Skywalker is on fire a little
Skywalker from perennial and we also
have look at this are you kidding me or
what then meant [__] cookies
perennial always throwing [__] heat
the uncle Joey ain't showing up with
[__] one gun and two bullets all [__]
[Music]
on the good time baby oh [__] here we go
way way down inside
[Music]
oh are you ready for the leaf on his
side he's been in training
[Music]
little bully is just getting warmed up
this is his third bong gift from his
whole existence and here's my main man
the producer produces a lighting
reminder for HP don't [__] around
I'm not [__] around but then [__] it
ones like you
there you go get that [__] right
here my love hit that meal they we go
hit that meal
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me or what
[__] shape on me girl I wanna be
your back door man are you [__] nuts
[Music]
have you seen the look on Bernie Sanders
face he's sick to his stomach can't even
see right now oh you'll need to see
Stevie Wonder's been walking around for
years he's doing fine everybody wants to
see [__] if you don't make the scene
keep it cooler baby if you're gonna go
[__] nuts tonight is the night
[__] we've been missing in
action its arms are sweaty everything
slammed on the Skywalk that is [__]
that on two legs you telling me apart if
I say to you tomorrow
take my hand child come with me
[__] it if we walk a nice let might as
well pass we didn't hook up with the
stars of death this week but we hooked
up with something that'll put us in hell
you understand me
[Music]
200 milligrams who says that warning
[__]
you know what warning means you dance on
this house look at least say that your
blood pressure went down hey man this is
what we [__] around with weed that your
blood pressure goes immediately down
yeah you understand me so if you got a
relative high blood pressure send them
over to the [__] office in two days I
have you down to 120 of 80 doing jumping
jacks and whistling Dixie you understand
me why I got the [__] program three
bong hits a day and dr. police is
breathe in out of your nose and in
through your nose with your helpful lip
a little wider than your [__] up dog
what do you think you're [__] deals
with your joint bananas we can you go
I can't oh [__] look at this right here
look at that green dick obsessed with my
uncle leaving
I missed you [__] but I'll tell
you later what happened to the house I
got [__] they're doing people to see
cops can't be coming to my house blow
this poor bastard look at you a soldier
in death look at this [__] google it
he went straight for the jugular let me
tell you something about the love of
this [__] company they say these
things are 200 milligrams bleep what do
you think how do all the experiments we
laugh they say it's 200 milligrams I tip
these at like 500 because we get
[Music]
warning understanding TKO [__]
that's right
[Music]
it's like Brock lesner on steroids I'm
saying that [__] much I'm happy all
you people that would jump it up and
down Brock is back you see that do you
see that you're [__] with I just over
there if you wake up with the sunrise
[Music]
and the oficina of the church
what's that leak you're ready for
another bucket oh [__] life and that's
it people you know I'm saying we got
ready for a podcast it's four hundred a
major accomplishment for me and this
poor little bastard at this time you
know we should have been in the rehab
let's try these think oh this is the
[__] this is the [__] that killed
grandpa right here from the grandpa you
left to go piss and you came back he was
dead on the rocking chair this is what
grandpa's smoked right here
here we go [__]
[Music]
then mints I swear to god people I'm
shaking right now from sk-1 I'm not
[__] with you we got some [__] here
that will [__] kill a monkey
understand because this is how we do we
have taste both [__] world
we got a taste aha a hybrid sativa with
us a teat with an indica straight-up
let's see what happens to you it's like
Israel yes Iran I'm saying it just don't
[__] mix it babe babe babe babe oh
yeah baby here we go load that bomb this
one's for the [__] Kennedys you know
I'm saying two down 18 to go what do you
do sit at home and listen to white
people ID how much [__] longer can
you listen to white people [__] lie
to you on that TV screen and you're
sitting there clapping even the black
people confuse how long how long stop
watching that convention take your wife
eat that ass and let's rock the
[__] house today it's the
Church of what's happening now I shoulda
quit you
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me a1 open the
door and let the bad spirits out of this
[__] office having been here
for three days
I gotta light the candle of life and
then please ready for his next [__]
bounty of death please bail right now
guys I'm telling you this guy walked
them look so [__] scary you know me
guys I don't give a [__] about a name I
don't give a [__] about a name some
people call it what some people call the
vagina some people call it bigger than
all [__] and at the end of the week
it's all the same you call this weed
whatever the [__] you what why do you
think I don't know the delivery service
because I'm gonna eyeball this
[__] before you show up but I
wanna go down soon and see all the goods
ain't one of these guys that gets
chopsticks with a microphone I don't
need that [__] I ain't that [__] much
of an [__] I just look at and if
there's a [__] look to it I could
just imagine what it looks like dry in
the car there's six seven hours in the
beaming Sun diesel and that's what I
show up with on a daily coz of the
eyeball you know I'm saying
Colorado mid 85s best weed was coming
out of those [__] mountains and I
would see these [__] me and I had been
grown up on Thai way from Harlem I never
saw this good [__] green [__]
muchas muchas dominocus [__]
[Music]
deep into the murky waters of the
underworld
[Music]
once you're talking about a bomb here
for I'm only talking to you people about
the [__] man chop steaks these people
like what a week scores may look at it
with chopsticks like they're [__]
important
[__] those [__] yeah we're magnifying
glasses right here the eyeball and I
need glasses but it's 30 [__] years
forty years I bought now listen you know
me accomplish my second life zero I
didn't get a [__] GED but I know one
thing reefer understand me
speaking of which Joey what's with the
chitter chatter drop a bomb on us is it
time for Lisa at people tell me babe
keep me satisfied
[Music]
I gave Lee it alight because you know
why because I love this [__]
this is for years you little [__]
wait watch your shirt let's do this [__]
[Music]
give it to another man hit this
[__] Lee there you go my god
let that flame of death
they kill that [__]
[Music]
you win a professional to burn in the
eighties that would put hairspray one -
burn my eyes out when he had them at
least you [__] give it a New York try
you know what time you got Lisa oh [__]
the Zeppelin's too [__] tough right
now Zeppelin - one of my all-time
favorite [__] house soon as I hear
this I think of a time playing the
[__] a guitar my room like a national
putting on to do all [__] at one
time I was an [__] who grew up to be
a [__] ass and what he gonna do here
we go what that's right you're high as
[__]
you know why that's the thin cookies
right there
[Music]
you [__] break it up I know you got
grandma's sleeping pill somewhere take
two of those things go a couple bong
hits a [__] whiskey on the rocks
they're not gonna be asleep in three
minutes you're going to a [__] name
into a [__] sedation for about 40
minutes before you pass out drooling but
you listen to a loud like this for on a
cool out what things I wish you were
here and let those sleeping pills go to
work instead you're a [__] sewage
[Music]
dump
oh [__] it's time for a bong hit we
didn't finish this little baby [__]
bar that I gave you I gave him a little
[__] [__] [__] the pot and he threw
me to the wheel we still got one more we
still got one more [__] sky only one
more because it's under Skywalker this
[__] back to take this to a time
when there was no rules there was no
animosity we all got along we smoked
dope
we drank a [__] a pack and everybody
went home nobody got shot you might get
robbed my [__] steal to Grandma bow
from me every day everybody went home
nobody went to the hospital I will keep
that's it what do you think it means to
have a good night
to jump up and down with a bunch of Jack
cause listen you get three for your
[__] goombah two broads you got a
couple of [__] eight-balls some
sleeping pills
let's up my two couple glasses of wine
who's that a [__] [__] the other two
look at each other and wipe off the debt
then you go to sleep everybody wakes up
[__] happy in the morning
[Music]
because not everybody's [__] handsome
like you wake this up with [__]
like me I was single for years just pump
it the victim saying you just get lucky
that's right what do you think I always
have a girl
I grew up to be a [__] man before
girl right that was a GDPs [__] job
was that [__] [__] when I was 20
that was the one that said Columbus is
shipping them saying oh [__] yet this is
not the police's breathing techniques
get the book briefed tell dump the
police I heard about it on the periscope
and I want to smoke pot like a [__]
Savage I want to [__] and take people
who smoke vapor plants and our [__]
vapor old-school
we get we [__] we're gonna start
the podcast in about ten minutes sit
tight we'll be back in your world
let Skywalker is [__] beso del
immortal thing I'll see you guys on
YouTube
Timmy jr. oh you [__] savages crystal
I love you guys John Cutler waterboxx
that lady Jake Leo my man [__] Leon
over there giving UFC predictions all
[__] dead oh no you do for a living
Leon Suarez
well [__] day you're on for the
[__] I get up in the middle of my
day you are talking about [__] Brock
lesner anyway I'll be back see in 10 if
the Sun we feels to Sun shall remain